you dropped out of school
because all you wanted to do was to
learn how to make movies yeah
that seems to me the only way to go you
know I mean film school was never an
option it just it seems to me to be
a waste of time and a waste of money you
know my my film education really came
from watching other movies you know
um
I think there's um
there's a scary mentality I think in
film schools my small sort of dealing
with them is is is something that's
really terrifying I walked into a film
class and it was about screenwriting and
this guy the first the opening line was
you know if you're here to write
Terminator 2 just leave now and I
thought well that's terrible there's it
could be a kid in the corner there that
wants to write Terminator too that's his
vision that's his movie that's what he
likes let him do it you know